you'll learn a lot from other writers
like there were writers on on man in the
high castle who won Emmys or you know
Martin Scorsese's best friend is another
one like like you you want to really
kind of learn from from the people
around you and that just makes you
better so I can't say that I have any
set process although right now as I'm
developing something I have to say I'm a
big fan of the John troubie
John troubie stuff I think he kind of
hits a sweet spot for me
genre is really the key to understanding
screenwriting today and it comes from
what I call the first Google apology
which is that Hollywood doesn't bind so
movie stars directors or writers it buys
and sells genres
now genres are story forms and more
importantly that they are the all-stars
of the story world they are story forms
that have been told over decades
centuries and in some cases like with
myth thousands of years so they've
already been worked out and they've been
worked out very very great detail and
they know exactly how their characters
work they know what their themes are
they know how the plot is going to work
and so on so it's very very tight now in
order to sell to a worldwide audience
you have to use these different genres
because this this is what the audience
is really buying one when an audience
goes to see one of the big summer
blockbuster films they may not know it
in their head oh that's a myth based
film or that's an action film or a
combination of the two but they know
what they like and that's what's
underneath each one of those stories
Avengers Dark Knight so on these are all
just basic story forms basic Jean with a
unique skin placement on top so it's
very important first of all for the
writer to understand what genre is they
are working in it's also very important
for them to understand how to combine
their genres because almost every film
that gets made now is not a Singlish
honor that was decades ago now almost
every film that gets made not just in
Hollywood but in worldwide cinema is a
combination of two three and sometimes
four genres now a lot of writers know
this what they don't know they usually
don't know is that combining genres is
varied
because each genre has its own hero
its own opponent its own desire line
theme and so on so when you start
combining these typically you end up
with chaos you end up with so many story
elements that are unconnected that the
script doesn't work so it's very
important to understand how to put these
genres together one final point about
this when a writer is developing a story
idea right at the beginning of the
writing process they come up against the
biggest decision that they will have to
make which is what genre is this story
the biggest reason that writers fail at
the premise and by the way 99% of
scripts fail at the premise line right
the very first decision in the writing
process
the biggest reason it fails is not that
it was wasn't a good idea it's that they
used the wrong genre to develop the idea
it used to be a very clear distinction
between film and television film was the
big I deal with the big spectacle
massive numbers of characters the epic
scale so on television was the intimate
story very personal just a very few
characters typically a drama but because
TV has evolved over the last 10 to 15
years in such a radical way this
distinction is now gone and in fact the
biggest spectacle stories are now in
television not in film you have a
fantasy show like Game of Thrones which
is as big an epic and spectacle as you
can get far bigger even than say Lord of
the Rings in terms of the number of
characters the story weaves all the
different storylines that are going on
the literal scope of where this story
takes place I mean it's a it's a
continent essentially so and and it's
covering multiple seasons this was the
big game change which is that in
television up to about 10 to 15 years
ago when we had almost strictly what
we're known as standalone shows
detective stories are standalone shows
where we introduce a problem in the
opening scene and we solve it by the
final descent and then next week we
reset the whole thing and we do it again
that meant that the the story scope was
about 45 minutes long now about 10 to 15
years ago writers began to realize that
the incredible power of the TV medium
for story because they realized that
instead of making the single episode the
way that we demarcate this the story
they realized it's the season that makes
the difference
we're gonna try to tell a story over an
entire season and so we had the
introduction of these serial shows as
opposed to standalone shows it meant
that the scope of television increased
radically because a season is
approximately 10 times longer than a
single feature film so that allowed us
many more characters it allowed us to
have a much more complex plot and this
changed everything in terms of the type
of story ideas that we would have an
television versus film
one of the biggest mistakes writers make
is in how they create character and they
they've heard this about you know we
need to care about the main character
which is absolutely true we do want to
care about that main character but how
they go about it is often wrong which is
they think that the way that you get an
audience to care about a character is
you make that character as detailed as
possible meaning we give them as many
character traits as we can this is not
the best way to go because those tend to
be very superficial elements of a person
and that's not what makes an audience
care about a character it's interesting
that what makes an audience care about a
character really comes down to only two
things the weakness the fundamental
weakness of that character and the
characters gold in the story this is why
in my my story classes it's always the
first thing I talk about and they are by
the way the first two steps of the seven
major story structure steps that I was
talking about earlier
weakness need of the character in other
words what is that personal problem
inside that is hurting the hero and such
a fundamental way that it's ruining
their life it's very deep and the entire
story is going to play out the soiling
of that problem the way they're going to
solve that problem is by going after a
particular goal they don't know at the
beginning that by going after this goal
they will eventually deal with their
great internal weakness but if it's a
good story that's exactly how it will
work you know I often talk about the
what I consider to be the most important
element of good writing the mark of a
really good storyteller
which is that plot comes from character
now those are big words and a lot of
people you hear that well what it
actually does that mean it means a lot
of things but the most important thing
it means is that you
create a goal for your hero which will
eventually force that person to deal
with their deep weakness if you do that
the plot comes from the deep source of
the character and you've told a great
story what we care about is to see a
character overcome a deep weakness now
the audience thinks that this story is
all about the hero achieving his goal
right because then we've got success and
that's important and in most stories the
hero will accomplish his goal by the end
of the story but that is not what the
audience is most interested in they
can't tell you this but we know from
lots of experience hundreds of years of
storytelling that the cave the real fact
is not does the hero accomplish the goal
but this is the hero overcome the great
weakness because that's what makes us
care about that character we see them in
pain we see them in trouble right if
they're already successful if they're
already a good and in some cases a
perfect person where do they go
all right there's nothing for them to
overcome so that's why it's so important
that we show in the very opening pages
of our script the great internal
weakness of our character now we may
also want to give them qualities that
are likable qualities that the audience
can also hook on to but those are not
nearly as important as establishing the
weakness upfront in the story
rewriting is one of the most
misunderstood of all of the major
writing steps partly because of that
famous line that you just stated writing
is rewriting there is no question of
that if you want to write a great piece
of storytelling you're going to have to
do a lot of rewriting but that concept
that writing is rewriting often makes
writers make a huge mistake right at the
beginning which is they think that my
first draft just get it on paper right
to overcome a whatever writing block
just get it down on paper don't try to
be perfect right because that just will
just stop you from writing entirely
alright okay so they get the script down
on paper and then they think okay I'll
fix any mistakes in the rewrite except
that they don't fix the mistakes in the
rewrite what people don't realize is
that first draft turns into concrete
when you've actually written it out and
it's on paper in many ways in your mind
it solidifies in such a way that it is
then very difficult to break that apart
and to make the key structural changes
that need to be made this is why in our
writers are shot when I tell them this
for most scripts the second draft is
worse than the first draft and it just
gets worse from there and that is
because of the approach that they take
to the script in the first place because
when you write that first draft some
fundamental things are going to be
embedded in that script this is why it
is so important that writers do a lot of
prep work before writing the first draft
starting all the way back with the
premise I always tell writers it is so
important to take a tremendous amount of
time exploring your premise line taking
weeks to look at just one sentence right
my one line
one sentence log one because you can
find a lot of the inherent structural
problems in your script that you're
going to encounter right there in the
first sentence now that also means we do
a lot of prep work in creating our
characters figuring out our structure
learning the end point of the story
before we begin writing so on and so
forth that doesn't mean that you're
going to again try to make that first
draft perfect what it does mean is that
you're going to be looking at what are
the embedded structural problems in this
story and try to make the fixes before
you actually write the draft and most of
those fixes will occur if you do your
prep work you can get a very good story
in the seam list the scene sequence now
this is in many ways a lot of type of
writers don't realize what an important
step this is in the writing process the
seamless the scene sequence because this
is the last place before you actually
write scenes to see the architecture of
your story for example I do a lot of
story consulting work and my preference
is don't give me a full script
give me your scene sequence I can spot
90% of your problems and come up with
the solutions right from the scene
sequence because if I see it as it is a
first draft of a script I've got all
that dialogue I've got a lot of
undergrowth that is hiding the bones of
the story and it's keeping me from
saying what is not working and how it
could be fixed so this is why it's so
important to do your craft homework
before writing the first draft and in
that first draft it will then make the
rewriting process so much simpler and it
will guarantee that your second draft is
better than your first draft
one more point about rewriting because
it is so misunderstood most writers
don't understand that rewriting is a set
of tools just like plot character and
soul and one of the key tools about
rewriting is the order that you rewrite
for example most writers the first thing
they fix when they're doing a rewrite
it's the dialogue it's the last thing
you should touch when I work with a
writer on a script we don't talk about
dialogue for the until the third or
fourth draft because it's all about
getting the story right and that's what
you want to focus focus on in your
rewriting here are the steps of finding
the structural problems and the first
step in finding the structural problems
of your script is go back to the desire
line of your story make sure that you
have a good strong spine you have a
desire line that will track and drive
this story from beginning to end
when I give classes the most common
question is all about how do I sell my
script
they wouldn't know there's an
implication in that question which is I
already know how to write a good script
the only thing I'm not able to do is
sell it not so 99% of writers you know
they will always talk in Hollywood about
it's all about the connections all about
whom you know
that's so overrated 99% of writers when
they finally meet somebody who is a
useful connection they don't have the
story tools to make that connection
payoff then we have the Kraft foundation
so it's all about you know this this
ability to treat writing as a profession
and part of that is I can never know
enough about how this craft works and
partly that's because every story is
different I'm talk to professional
writer friends and we're always amazed
we think okay it's going to get easier
now it doesn't it gets harder because
the better you get the higher you set
the bar for yourself on your script
Evaristo cracking a story is always hard
no matter how much you know because
every story is totally new
yeah there's certain elements that you
can use that you can hang your hat on
you can you can get it a way into the
story and so on but everyone is tough so
that's why this is having this
professional approach to being a writer
being a storyteller is so important it's
the only thing that eight makes you
successful but B gets you through I
almost tell writers this you can have a
lot more ideas on this life than you
ever have time to write
the full-length script or not so always
write a story that you both care about
and that you think will have an appeal
to a larger audience it can always be
done
it's all about is it on the page one of
the advantage that we have as writers /
actors is that we don't have to what
dishing in person right they don't have
to reject us personally right it can be
on the page I can be writing on Mars if
it's on the page
I don't care where you're from I don't
care what you look like right if it's on
the page and it's a good script and this
is another reason why it's so important
to prove yourself on the page to prove
that you've got the correct and I always
tell writers if you have a script that
is rejected it isn't necessarily
rejected because the quality of writing
wasn't there most of the time it is
rejected because that producer didn't
simply didn't like that story idea
didn't feel that it was a commercial
idea for what they wanted to try to sell
you can't get as the writer you can't
have any control over that the only
thing you have control over is the
quality of writing on the page if you do
your job and master the crap so that you
get that quality on the page at some
point you will break through I true I
believe that 20 years ago I believe it
now and again for most writers they
think that they've done that craft work
on they really have
right lock of course is a big problem
that writers every writer faces at some
time or another I think it's a big
misconception that writer's block comes
from some kind of a psychological
element that we face of that
oh I'm just not in a creative place
right now you know I've been working on
the story for too long
whatever the reason that we come up with
I find almost every time writer's block
comes from not understanding the true
structure of the story you're telling
and buddy when I say true structure I
mean not only is it hitting those key
story beats that I referred to a little
earlier but is it kidding the story
beats that are unique and right for that
story and almost always it comes down to
that main character because the main
character drives the story and the key
to having a truly creative script a
truly creative story unique from
anything that anybody has ever seen
before including the writer is that
unique main character because that's the
person that you know this is a unique
individual and that's the unique
individual that will drive the story so
whenever I see a writer who is running
into creativity problems running into
writer's block of some sort I always say
go back to your main character find out
what is unique about that person that
you haven't thought of so far and find
out what is unique about that character
that you are passionate about why do you
want to tell this person story once you
focus in on that character and the
unfolding of that character over the
course of the story then you will get
back in touch with your real creativity
and I find almost
every time that that will break the
writer's block and break very quickly
it's always important to have a sense of
writing for an audience in other words
I'm not just writing for myself I'm not
just writing for my immediate family I
want to write a script that a lot of
people want to see but it's very tricky
in terms of what steps you take based on
that as I mentioned earlier it's not
about predicting a trend it's not about
predicting what it's going to be hot
with an audience it's once you determine
certain basic elements that oh this can
be a commercial story an idea then it's
all about forgetting that and getting to
what I call the gold of the idea getting
down into what is totally unique about
that story idea keep mine the biggest
reason is script fail
match that 99% of scripts fail at the
premise one when we've only written one
sentence and the biggest reason that
they fail is it wasn't an original idea
in the first place right yeah the
writers make all kinds of mistakes when
it comes to developing that idea but if
you don't start off with the original
idea in the first place
it's not going to be an original script
and although it has no interest in that
right why are they gonna pay the kind of
money that it's paid per scripts for
something that any number of a hundred a
thousand people could write so and and
what most writers don't realize is
because it's so difficult to dig into an
ID and finally is truly original about
it most writers come up with a premise
that is a copy of a movie they saw six
months ago or it's a copy of two movies
that they put together that they saw six
months ago right that's that doesn't
make it original so it's very important
that once you have that idea that you
explore it very deeply find out what is
original about it and if the idea is not
original it's important
that you're not right now this is
counter to what most writers do most
writers when they come up with an idea
they immediately start writing script
pages it's one of the clearest marksman
amateur and what happens of course is
they get 15 20 pages in that write
themselves into a dead end they just
remembered another idea now over years
and years of experience that I've had as
a writer story consultant I have found
that most ideas should not be written
the scripts and it's exactly the
opposite of when I started when I
started I thought there isn't a story
idea that I can't make work as a script
but I can't make work as a full-length
story over years of experience have
found just the opposite is the case
that the real value of exploring your
premise taking time to make sure its
original taking time to find out what
the structural problems are inherent to
the idea the big value of that comes
from finding out that nine out of ten
ideas that you have should not be
written because the single biggest
choice that a writer makes in the entire
writing process what story do I write
not how do I write it yeah there's a lot
of decisions that go into that but the
most important decision is what story do
it right in the first place
most stories are so full of structural
problems that are embedded in the idea
they will not be solved I don't care how
good you are at story you will not solve
those problems so why take months and
months and a lot of pain to write that
as a full length script just to find out
oh I didn't solve those structural
problems after writing the script and I
knew what they were ready to be getting
right the premise idea
that is one of the most important things
that you want to figure out not
necessarily right at the premise line
but pretty close which is what is the
structural endpoint of my story
and a lot of writers ask me to say so
look you know I like to be more creative
as the term that they used as though
figuring out the end point of the
structure is uncreated in fact the
opposite is the case the better you are
in structure the more creative the
script because what structure does is it
allows you to know what will work and
what won't work so that you know oh I
can take this really cool creative twist
here because I've got the structural
scratch scaffolding underneath it to
support it or I don't have it right so
that's why knowing that end point is one
of the I'd say five most important
techniques in all of stories keep in
mind that that every story is a journey
of learning that the hero takes over the
course of that story and in any journey
you take you cannot take the first step
unless you know where you're going to
otherwise you're gonna walk around in
circles same is true in the writing
process and just because you figure out
the structural endpoint of your story
doesn't mean that you can't change that
down the road it just means that it is
going to give you a focus point for
every other structure step that that
story is going to take
coupe anger is a very important
technique in television and cliffhanger
is simply a moment in this story when
the hero is in maximum danger but
instead of playing out that event to its
conclusion we stop it right before it
gets resolved typically with the hero at
their weakest point they are hanging
from a cliff right and so why would we
have a cliffhanger what's the value of
stopping that scene right there and
going to a different storyline the idea
is we're trying to hold the audience so
that we can get them to come back this
is why we often get cliff hangers in
television right before commercial
because we'll want to try to hold on to
them so they don't go to another show
using the remote control now the way is
written into the script you don't of
course say well this is a cliffhanger
you don't need to write anything
differently to say that's a cliffhanger
it is a cliffhanger by virtue of what
happens in the action so the real trick
here is not how do you write it in the
script the real trick is how do you set
it up in the story and to do that what
you have to do is have at least one
other major action line that you can cut
to you cannot have a cliffhanger if you
have a single story line so where you
get it is in a show with multiple
storylines that are unfolding
simultaneously and then at the crucial
moment you stop one story line jump over
to the next story line then you take
that to a cliffhanger jump back to the
first line resolve the cliffhanger there
and take them to the next step
I like to talk when I get my class I
like to talk about the story elements
that are found in hit films because
writers don't realize that in order to
sell a script they have to write the
script that Hollywood is looking to buy
now to understand what that is you have
to understand that what Hollywood's
basic marketing requirement is which is
they are selling to a worldwide audience
now for years now it has not been the
u.s. audience that they're most
concerned about it's a worldwide
audience and it turns out that to sell
to a worldwide audience to have a
blockbuster know there are certain story
elements that are in those blockbuster
scripts and a lot of writers don't
realize this they think that well it's a
blockbuster film because it has movie
stars or because it has a lot of special
effects and so on well not so Hollywood
has not been a movie star based system
for at least a decade even though most
people think that it still is all about
the movie star no it's about the script
and it's about the story elements that
are in the script now there are certain
story elements that writers have to have
in their script to appeal to a worldwide
audience because we have to get beyond
those cultural differences those
national differences so the first thing
that you realize when you look at these
hip films it is that they're almost
always based on the myth genre myth form
is the most popular story form in the
world and has been for many years and in
the case of both Hunger Games and The
Avengers
we have myth based stories which have
then been updated now in the case of the
Avengers we have another really good
story element that they use which is the
concept of the dream team the All Stars
that are brought together and this is a
very popular story form when you combine
that with a myth based story you've got
a big hit on you
and by the way that's the main reason
that Disney bought Marvel comics in the
first place was to get access to what I
call the character Bank which is a
number of characters that are already
established have worldwide appeal and
which we can then use in any number of
films ad infinitum in the case of The
Hunger Games you have a very good
adaptation I think of a book in the
sense of that once again we have this
myth Foundation and in this particular
case the novelist is really the person
who brought all those myth elements
together very similar to the way
JK Rowling did in the Harry Potter
stories you get this element of the
young female Archer that this is right
out of Greek mythology Artemis Diana
character you get the William Tell story
with her shooting the arrow through the
the apple and so on but she brought
together all of these classic myth
elements and put them in a story which
he then modernized using a science
fiction form so again we get a very
powerful combination of myth and science
fiction that again made for a worldwide
hit
it goes back to that first rule of
Halloween which is that Hollywood
marketing is based on selling genres now
that means that everyone who has any
sense of how Hollywood works now knows
that if you want to be in the game you
have to write a genre based story now
they're not that many different major
genres they're twelve major genres that
99.9% of Hollywood films get made from
typically in combination of those twelve
now
there's the problem which is that if
everybody is writing a genre script and
genres of course have essentially had
anywhere from 8 to 15 basic story beats
that must be present in that script if
you are writing that genre script
properly if all you do is write that
genre in its normal way you're going to
write a script that everybody else is
writing that has no chance to sell and
this is why in my class I'm constantly
talking about these are the beats of the
genre which gets you in the game
well I've referred to it as paying the
dues hitting the beats of the genre but
then you got to go beyond that which
gives you have to transcend the genre
you have to write above it you have to
twist the genre in such a way that the
audience hasn't seen before which means
that you take those 8 to 15 basic beats
and for each one of them you do them in
a unique way that the audience that
surprises the audience and notice that
what you get there when you transcend
the genre is you get to have you taking
you to two which is you give the
audience all the genre beats that
they're coming to that movie to see but
you're also surprising them you're
putting a different skin on those bones
in a way that they haven't seen before
so they get that
pleasure and that is the only way in my
opinion that a writer can break through
from the crowd and have their scripts
stand out
I found over many years of experience in
working with writers that the biggest
mark of an amateur is the inability to
take criticism now it's certainly
understandable why somebody would not
want to hear that criticism they have
put their heart and soul into that
script and in many ways what is in that
script is blame themselves bear for the
public and this is a scary thing and so
if somebody doesn't like your script
they don't like you but that is not the
way to become a great writer you have to
be able to listen to criticism because I
don't care how good a writer you are you
cannot write the perfect script you have
everybody has weaknesses in their
writing everybody has weaknesses in a
particular script so the trick is if I'm
going to improve that script I have to
be able to listen to outside criticism
now then the very important thing comes
into play which is who is giving you
that criticism right most people are not
capable of giving a writer useful
criticism either because they do not
have the structural tools or because
they are too to personally connect to
that writer right if I give a family
member my script what kind of comments
am I going to get back right it's not
going to be a they're going to be afraid
to be negative and B they're not trying
to give me the kind of feedback that can
actually make a difference in my script
now this includes a lot of people that
you know in the executive suite that
that are going to be giving you feedback
on a script producers agents and so on
unfortunately a lot of them are not
trained to give a writer commentary that
can
truly improve the script and a lot of
times they will give commentary that is
contradictory
they'll tell them the right to
fundamentally opposite things and the
writer cannot do them both right there
they're opposite so it's so important
that you not only be open to outside
criticism but that you're getting
criticism from people who know what
they're talking about because the only
criticism that actually works for you
that is not destructive is structural
criticism in other words looking at the
bones of the story and telling you what
is not working and I have found that
writers who get constructive criticism
structural criticism they love that
because it's not personal it's about the
craft and it's only the craft that can
make that script better and
unfortunately very few people are able
to give that kind of structure of prison
this is also why I always recommend two
writers form writer groups preferably
with the best writers you know because
then you're going to be talking the same
language you're gonna be talking this
structural language because any writer
has been writing for any length of time
and is really concerned about improving
their craft they know this they know
that it's all about the structure and so
when you are in a writers group within
getting feedback from other writers you
know that you're getting the stuff that
really makes a difference under the
surface that the average audience member
the person cannot give you
typically when an audience is giving you
feedback it's it's a lot of it is about
the pace a lot of it is about it's all
some version of it was slow here I
didn't like that character I didn't like
that scene so on and so forth what
they're really talking about is that the
sequencing of the scenes the building of
the story is not right it's not working
for them but last year was was part of a
screening in a film that I worked on and
we found from the audience that they
were having a lot of problems especially
with the final third of the film and we
realized we we had for various reasons
we had a big hole about two-thirds of
the way in the film and we thought we
needed those beats those scenes because
to tell the story but the audience
showed us that we did not need those and
so what we did was we basically cut out
about five or six scenes that we thought
had to be in there for the detailing for
the building of the character over the
course the story turned out we could
pull out all six of those scenes and
boom which would give us the drive into
the final part of the story and didn't
cause a problem at all and instead it
gave us the pacing that we needed to
bring the audience along all the way to
the end of the story so typically that's
it's some version of that because
there's a feeling that the audience has
they again they're not they're not
trained to specifically know why a story
is not building they just know it's not
working for me keep in mind - I've seen
a lot of films and they may not be able
to speak in the language of the writer
of the filmmaker but they know what is
not working for them
and so if you as the writer or filmmaker
can listen and be open to that
I have found time and again getting
really good feedback from from an
audience just the normal audience out
there that was very helpful because it
goes back to the old concept of the
custard the customer is always right
right you you can't if you're writing a
script you can't you know and and and a
reader says oh this didn't work for me
you can't say well let me explain you
what I was trying to do if you if they
didn't like it it's your fault it's not
their fault so it's very important to be
open to to any kind of criticism and if
you know how listen you can often find
out some very good things about a script
or a film that you did not know
going back to that premise line and it's
also again it goes back to crap one of
the things they spent a lot of time in
it in Miami story master class is
techniques for breaking down the premise
there are actual techniques that you use
to see is this a good story idea it's
not just oh I'm excited about that I did
know it's about okay how do I find out
how this is going to work as a hundred
to 120 page script right that that takes
technique to be able to jump ahead again
we only have one line here I need to be
able to figure out how this is going to
work as a hundred two hundred and twenty
page prep so that requires a number of
techniques give you an example you look
at that premise idea and the first thing
you look for is there a desire line
embedded in this idea that can track 100
pages that can extend for on your pages
most premise ideas don't have that no
thing you look at is there a main
opponent in this idea who can fight with
the hero over that length of time and
can create ongoing conflict for the
entire story most premise ideas don't
have that either so this is again going
back to having the tools get word to do
your job and at the same time CPUs to
save yourself a lot of pain and wasted
writing that kills most writers I mean
you write a few of those scripts in a
row where you go through all that
trouble to write the script only to find
out that the script is not going to work
no matter what you do you have to be
writing for very long right it's one of
the biggest reasons right excuse me one
of the biggest reasons writers give up
these character is far what I call the
in-between characters of the story
because we have on one side the hero and
the heroes allies on the other side we
have that main opponent and any
secondary opponents that you may have in
the story right these are clear
characters in opposition but one of the
keys to plot if not the key to long is
surprise revealed we want to not only
surprise the hero over the course of the
story we want to surprise the audience
that's essentially what plot is the
question is how do we get reveals how do
we get surprises we give them a lot of
different ways but one of the most
important ways is with these in between
characters character who appears to be
an ally that is real an opponent
somebody who appears to be an opponent
but it's really a moment every time the
audience sees that somebody they thought
was one it turns out to be another
that's a review that's a plot beat and
that's what the audience goes oh yes
that was really great thank you that's
the power plot and these characters are
one of the main ways that we get these
surprises for the audience now to see
the value of this character take a look
at the Harry Potter stories and of
course most obvious example of this is
Snape who switches back and forth
between a parent Ally and a parent
opponent for seven books right that's
how useful this character this type of
character is because every time he
switches we surprise the audience she
was able to sustain that source of plot
for seven full books this is one of the
ways that we know that she's a master
it's just that technical long cheap
course many many others that she was
used but that's more most important
knowing your genre is extremely
important in television just as it is in
a film because the genre that you're
working in gives you the primary beats
the unique story beats that must be in
your script if you're going to be doing
that show properly now as I mentioned
before television now covers all of the
major genres from detective and crime
all the way through the fantasy science
fiction horror soap opera legal drama
doctor drama so on and these all work in
radically different ways
each of those genres has its own set
story beats and this is why in all of
the classes that I teach including the
television class I spend a great deal of
time going through all the beats of each
one of those genres in the case of
television though it's also this I wish
it was simpler but it's not
but in television is not just knowing
the beats of that particular genre that
you're working in it's also
understanding how those beats are
changed by the fact that is on
television not in film because keep in
mind again the difference the primary
difference is in film we've got a
two-hour unit that's all we have to do
with TV the key feature is what I call
extendibility we need to be able to take
a story form and extend it not only over
one season potentially 24 episodes of
one season but over five seasons so it's
got to be and that that changes the
genre itself because then what you can
do in that genre is very different when
you're having to do it in two hours
versus over five years
the advent of serials has totally
changed not just how story works in
television but how viewers react to that
how yours experience television now
binge viewing of course doesn't exist
when we're talking about say a detective
show a standalone show you wouldn't sit
there and watch ten episodes at the
castle because every one of those is
essentially the same story binge viewing
happens when you have a serial whether
it's in drama or in comedy and these
Netflix these sorts of shows are a good
example of that I remember last summer
they AMC put on Breaking Bad from the
very beginning to their most recent
episode
now when Breaking Bad first came out I
wasn't interested in watching and I
thought all this is another show about a
guy who who sells drugs you know who
needs to see this it's gonna be the same
old thing well when they put it on in
one a day which essentially allowed me
to binge view for you know for a month
and a half on Breaking Bad the
experience of that show was totally
different because what I was able to see
is not only why this is one of the
greatest TV shows that it's ever been
done but I got to see why it's one of
the greatest shows ever done and it had
to do with the ability of that writing
staff to not only write great individual
episodes but to sequence the episodes of
the course of the season and ultimately
over the course of the entire show and
it was almost like wine tasting and I
think that's what what binge viewing is
like because when you're wine-tasting
you immediately get to compare these
different wines and it becomes very
clear why this line is better than that
wine when you do binge viewing you get
to the links
in the episodes become much clearer and
you see the true artistry of the
storytellers in their ability to build a
series of episodes to the climactic
final episode of that season and then to
with whole certain things that have to
be withheld to set up the opening
episode of the next season and so this
this whole use of the serial writing is
causing people to have an entirely
different experience of how they watch
television and how they appreciate
television because they think this is
also one of the places where people are
realizing that the best story work in
American entertainment business is in
television right now and and by the way
do classes all over the world the single
biggest interest wherever I go is to
talk about and understand American
television because they understand that
the quality of American television is
the highest it has ever been it is the
best in the world and they want to know
how can they do it too
over the years writers have taken total
control of the medium and in my view
this is the single most important reason
why the writing in television is better
than any other medium in American
entertainment writers have control the
medium not directors not producers not
movie stars and the result is plain for
everybody to see it used to be that film
was thought as the little brother the
you know oh well if you can't make it in
film well you can maybe try television
well that's completely flipped now and
again it's because of this fracture
audience film still they're trying to
appeal to a worldwide audience that's
even bigger than 30 million people
they're trying to get people all over
the world which is why the differences
of what we see in film are now the
narrowest it's ever been would basically
have out of Hollywood superhero movies
that's it yeah at Oscar time you'll get
maybe the five films that Hollywood made
that year that are dramas that are
serious works of art that we then get to
nominate for Best Picture and then
everybody forgets that for the whole you
know other 11 and a half months of the
year they're putting out superhero
movies comic book hero movies that's
because that's that that's that story
form that genre which is essentially
myth plus action appeals to the largest
number of people in various cultures
around the world TV doesn't have that
requirements so you can do things as
different is Breaking Bad Game of
Thrones Downton Abbey The Good Wife and
so on and the quality within those
genres on TV is so high if you look at
say the nine major TV genres you could
argue that want seven of those not
we have the best show of that genre
right now on that we've ever had that's
phenomenal
well first of all you've got to have a
really good spec script and what a lot
of writers think is that the big
obstacle is sending the script in and
that certainly is an obstacle because
you do need an agent to get it through
the door to have somebody look at it but
by far the bigger obstacle of that
writers face is writing a spec script
that's good enough to be sent in in the
first place and this is where learning
the craft is so important and we're
writing a spec script of a particular
show and executing it really well is so
important
keep in mind that when you send a spec
script in it will be read by someone of
oh whatever shows they send the spec
script to it will be read by somebody on
that show and what they're looking for
is did you execute the way this show is
done because each show has a very
specific set of rules so we do these
things and we don't do those things and
if you don't know that and you make the
mistake for example some shows do not
have cliffhangers they won't do that and
if you write cliffhangers in your
episode it's out they want to see can
you write this show because remember
that that's very challenging for writer
this is not something that you are
creating from scratch as you would with
a spec movie script this is you are
writing a story for a show that's
already been created for characters that
have already been created can you get
your voice into that show that's what
they're looking for and can you tell a
great story one of the things I always
talk about in the TV sitcom class is
that the perception of writers trying to
break in is that a sitcom is stringing
as many jokes as you can get in 22
minutes it's all about the jokes can
you make people laugh when they read the
scrip certainly the jokes are important
but any producer on any sitcom on the
air will tell you that what they look
for in a spec script is the story they
can add the jokes later they're not
worried about that what's hard to come
up with is a sitcom story that will be
appealing to the audience that can be
the structure the framework to hang the
jokes on and that's a talent most
writers don't have so again I'm just
trying to get the focus onto the real
problem that has to be solved if you're
a writer trying to break in which is
write a great spec script because this
is the calling card that makes all the
difference that is what makes or breaks
your career if you want to work in
television do you have to know that show
top to bottom and that's why as I was
saying earlier one of the ways you
determine which show to write for is
it's not just a show that's highly
respected by the critics that's popular
with the audience it's a show that you
love that you watch religiously so that
you really know how that thing works
that's what they're looking for under
the surface
the fact is that creative writing is the
loneliest job in the world no matter
what medium you are working in it's just
that the pace of television writing is a
hundred times what it is in any other
medium whether it's writing novels film
whatever it might be and so the the
downside of that is that your you know
the the requirement that you generate
good product in a short period of time
is intense the pressure on these people
is intense
but there's some positives one is you
don't have writer's block right because
with those kind of deadlines writer's
block disappears and you find all of a
sudden when you have everything you do
has an intense deadline that luxury of
writer's block just disappears you're
gonna have to write something the other
great advantage is that you are writing
on staff and writing snaps of a very
interesting animal especially for the
psychology of the writer because even
though writing is extremely lonely and
the sense of self-criticism is intense
for all writers when you work with the
staff it's all about cracking stories
because we have to come up with a new
story every week and we have to have
that story worked out beat for beat
literally figure out every scene every
story event before it goes to script and
the way it's done is it's done with
everybody's in the room together
cracking stories together and that's why
in in a writers room every wall is
filled with the board's the big boards
and the three by five cards that lays
out every episode of the season and all
of the story events in every episode and
so that we
wires tremendous brain power all working
together and the the great part about it
probably the best part about it is that
you were in effect working in a band
you're playing in a band you and this is
these are some of the best story people
working in the world and when you're in
a room with these kind of people at that
kind of quality it and it's and it's all
working well it's Reiter's heaven
because it you know I equated it's like
playing with the Rolling Stones it's
that's how good these people are they're
all graded story they're all graded
script and so you get this
cross-pollination of ideas these these
these spitballing sessions where they
break down a story and it appears before
your eyes and it's just phenomenal
just to go through that process
especially if you love story you love
writing as much as I do
there is no preparation for the
psychological difficulty of working in
that environment yes the the the fun of
creating story with these other story
champions is tremendous but the politics
is intense the competition is intense
sometimes there's backstabbing that goes
on you know I think anybody's worked on
staff will tell you that there is a
tremendous very clear hierarchy that
you're dealing with starting at the top
with the showrunner and how that
showrunner runs the staff makes all the
difference in the world but you have to
be able to attach your ego to the larger
world to the larger goal of making this
show and every episode of the show work
and that means not only being part of
the team and especially when you're
starting out being at the low part of
the team it also means the requirement
to be able to write other people's
characters and not every writer can do
that that is probably the most difficult
part about it because you have to in you
have to absolutely submerge yourself
into that the show creators vision and
if you can't do that then you don't want
to be writing for television it's only
at the beginning you're a small part you
you your part will grow but your part is
really B it's it's tremendously
egalitarian in the sense that whoever
comes up with the best story idea wins
so you can have a tremendous impact on
any show that you work for as long as
you know your story skills that's what I
always tell writers that's what you're
really training for it's become great at
story because that's what that's what
they're dying for that's what they have
to generate so fast but where you have
to really mold your ego is to understand
that anything you create
even your own scripts will be changed
dramatically and oftentimes a script
that you write that has your name on it
when it finally gets to fill it doesn't
have a single word of what you wrote and
if you can't handle that again you don't
want to write for television essentially
24 hours they eat sleep talk story and
write story all the time I remember the
we used to have to show up by 10:00 a.m.
they said well that's a late start
except it we the earliest we got out of
that room was midnight and typically in
2 to 3 o'clock in the morning and then
you go home you get some sleep just
enough time to wake up and go back in do
it for another 12 hours 12 to 14 hours
and a lot of times seven days a week
again it depends a lot on the showrunner
certain show runners they want to make
it a livable experience they don't want
it to be hell to work on the show and so
they try to be very organized and they
try to give you at least one day off a
week and so on but if the show is not
that organized or the showrunner doesn't
work that way then you're you're in it
you know for 24/7 there's a bit again
the upside is that that would be the
greatest training in writing that you
will ever get and once you've gone
through it you are completely changed as
a writer because the again the
psychological shock is your biggest
problem because there the requirement to
produce quality material that fast is
something you have no matter how much
training you've done in the past no
matter how many screenplays you've
written whether you've written novels
plays and so on it will not prepare you
for what you're about to face
and the psychological hit is the thing
you've got to be worried about
especially right at the beginning it so
it's like being a rookie and anything
when you first get their first break in
the adaptation that you have to do to
what's going on in that world is and on
the writing level is intense but it's
also you have to adjust to the
psychology of the fact that you
literally have no time for personal life
and and especially if you're writing for
a network show where you have up to 24
episodes per season by the time you're
done with that season that about nine
months you you are this close to being
dead I remember it at the end of the
season on Jump Street the head of the
studio came to the showrunner and said
this was one of Fox's early shows and it
was it was in many ways created Fox it
made Fox happen and so Jump Street with
Johnny Depp was super popular and so the
executive came to the showrunner said we
need two more episodes
well we'd already done 22 23 24 episodes
and the showrunner said sorry
the horses are dead we can't get
anything more out of them they just
cannot go any farther that was the kind
of intensity that one season produced on
the staff
you are crafting
or serial television are they all the
same be and the answer is no they're not
and this is both one of the strengths of
the serial and one of the problems for
serial with stand alone the beats are
always the same how you fill those beats
are different so for example we always
have a murder committed in the opening
scene right and then we're going to go
through the beats of solving that murder
by the end of that episode with serial
one of the major ways that it's
different structurally from standalone
is that each episode will be much more
diverse to be you can have episodes
within a serial that are radically
different than other episodes and it all
comes down to one of the keys
structurally for how you write
television whether it's standalone or
serial which is the desire line what did
the heroes of that episode want in that
episode now in standalone that desire
line will be very restricted for example
the detective it's to solve the crime in
serial because we have so many more
characters each with their own desire
line what when we segment each of this
of these season long experience into
individual episodes what those
characters want at any one time will be
radically different and this is the the
downside of that is it's unpredictable
for the audience and if you like that
standalone experience this is just too
much change and difference and I don't
know did we win on this or did we lose
what what happened here but for people
who love the serial form they like that
diversity they like the fact that they
can't predict what is going to happen
one episode was it's totally based on
cross-cutting among all of these
different characters each with their own
desire line
I have seen so many movies and read some
these scripts that couldn't even begin
to count which one I've done more of but
they're both very important if somebody
wants to write screenplays
professionally and I say that for two
reasons first of all when it comes to
watching film that's really where I
learned my training as a writer and
where I developed all my techniques
having to do with how do you write a
script that will make a great film what
I did was for about a three year period
I went to classic cinema and watched to
you know really high level films a day
and took notes in the dark and what I
was looking for were the patterns what
were the elements that were found in
every great film do such elements even
exist and I found that they did and from
that I was able to develop really the
centerpiece of what I talked about in
story which is the seven key steps of
every great story from that I also then
developed the more detailed 22 steps of
every great story these are steps in
every good script no matter how long no
matter how short no matter what medium
no matter what genre and these are
really the keys to successful story tell
now it's also important that writers
read a lot of scripts because it's only
by reading a lot of scripts that you get
a sense especially of the pacing that a
professional script has and you only see
that when you've read a lot of but once
you've read a lot of them you see how
quickly does this story get established
in the script because keep in mind that
the reader the person that we need to
get through in order to sell that script
the reader has read many many scripts
and their normal response to a script is
no so we have to break that pattern in
their mind now they form that know in
their head in the first 10 pages and so
reading a lot of scripts gives the
writer a sense of what do I have to have
accomplished in those first 10 pages to
keep the reader reading and to give them
a chance to say yes
this is one of the common and most
important distinctions that is often
made when we're talking about writing
professionally but there is a basic
misunderstanding that's going on there
that is putting them these two things in
opposition to each other and in fact way
I like the way I like to look at it is
that understanding the craft of writing
a big part of that is dealing with it in
a businesslike way now when most writers
think about the business of story
whether it be in film or television
they're thinking in terms of writing a
story writing an idea that can sell big
mistake nobody can predict what will
sell nobody can predict what is
commercial and if you try to do that you
will always fail and you'll you know
have a constant frustration for the rest
of your life through like the rest of
your writing like instead what I try to
purge writers to do is to approach their
craft in a businesslike way which means
first of all learn the craft learn the
craft don't think it's all about who I
know no it's all about is it on the page
did you write a great script but then
treating your craft in a businesslike
way also has to do with do I can I
create this script in a particular genre
that the entertainment business is going
to buy there are certain genres not
story ideas that are commercial there
are certain genres that are more
commercial than others there are certain
genres for example that we get in
television that we get a lot of for
example dr. dramas legal dramas
detective stories so in treating your
craft in a businesslike way
it means how do I take the steps that I
need to take to have a career as a
writer to be paid as a writer
professionally over many years in fact
in in my TV class the entire TV class is
structured according to the steps that
the writer has to go through to make a
career out of writing for television and
that includes things like how do you
write your spec script which show do you
choose to write your spec script for
what must be in that spec script what
are the beats of the genre that you're
gonna have to hit for that spec script
to work and so on that's you can see
that the in all of those things craft
and being businesslike are the same and
the big problem that I always have with
writers who have this tremendous desire
to write professionally is they think in
the old romantic tradition of it's all
about getting that inspiration from
above and somehow just creating this
perfectly written or well-structured
well-written script and that has nothing
to do with how a great script is written
or be how a great script is sold so
that's why I put so much emphasis in my
classes on taking a businesslike
approach to your craft if you want to
write professionally and I always love
this metaphor you know I would love to
be the starting point guard for the
Lakers right but I can't walk onto the
court and say hey you know Kobe's
injured now so I really like to play
just because you really want to do it
doesn't mean you get to do it those
players have years of training and
they've approached their sport as a crap
where they learn all the skills they
practice them ad infinitum and now
they're ready to perform on the at the
professional level storytelling for film
and television is at least
competitor as professional sports so you
have to have that same approach in order
to succeed